hey grammarians today we're going to be
talking about correlative conjunctions
and i know this looks like a pretty ugly
word correlative like it's kind of
complicated looking but let's break it
down this copart comes from a latin com
meaning with or together
and relative when we know what the word
relative is like your aunt or your uncle
or your cousin is a relative
so we're just going to say that just
means relative or related
so correlative conjunctions there we see
it definitionally are or etymologically
are related together in some way they're
they're matched pairs they're a matching
set
and this just means that when you see
one it's probably time to use the other
in this video we'll go through five of
my favorites
so either or is a good pair to start off
with and when you start a sentence with
either or either i don't know how you
say it
it sets up the expectation that you're
going to have to be choosing between two
things so we're going to say or later in
the sentence
as in what is reputed to be oscar
wilde's last words either the wallpaper
goes or i do
the opposite
of either or
is neither nor
so either or sets up this choice between
two options and neither nor rejects both
options so neither gia nor becca liked
howard
and i recognize that i say neither and
some of you say neither and there's a
whole george gershwin song about that
but let's just chalk it up to my
midwestern american accent how about
neither either neither neither let's
learn about some conjunctions
but oh
if we talk about the both then you use
and and oh
if you learn to use conjunctions that is
grand oh yes
both bigby and ledoux were career
criminals
where we're using both to indicate a
connection between two things and then
we use and later in the sentence to
really firm that up
as so uh is kind of an interesting one
it's a little formal
um and it kind of allows you to set up
this relationship of consequence right
to say if one thing is happening then
another thing happens as a consequence
so
as goes kansas so goes the nation
so you know
as as one thing happens so must another
thing happen is what this is trying to
set up
whether and or
is similar to either and or except it
has
a kind of whiff of possibility about it
whether you like shrimp or chocolate
there's certainly something for you at
the veracruz food fair
right because weather is kind of setting
up this possibility between these two
options and it doesn't really matter
which one you choose there it's just a
it's just offering up possibilities and
i would like to offer you the
possibility of checking out more of
these correlative conjunctions in our
exercises so stick around
you can learn anything
david out